okay so this is a paper entitled a
structure in the early universe at said
of order 1.3 that exceeds the
homogeneity scale of the rw concordance
cosmology that's quite a mouthful for a
title that is
not a catchy title it isn't really a
catchy title no um but the physics and
the astronomy behind it is rather
interesting
give me a give me a better title
um
the discovery of an implausibly large
structure in the universe
that's better you should have written
there's some big structure out there a
long way away from us and
it's there they argue they're saying
it's the biggest structure that there is
in the universe so this is basically uh
collaboration which are looking at
quasars in the universe are these very
bright active nuclei and galaxies not to
study the quasars themselves but because
where there's a quasar there's a galaxy
so they're a good way of figuring out
where galaxies are in the universe where
the galaxies themselves are too faint to
see
and they're mapping out these quasars in
three dimensions to figure out whether
they're randomly spread in space or
whether they're clustered together and
if they are clustered together how
they're clustered together such a large
structure is incompatible with a
universe
which is homogeneous on very large
scales homogeneous means you're in no
special place
that what we see around us is
representative of everywhere else in the
universe
and so um you don't expect though that
the argument goes i'm not so sure i i
buy it yet you don't expect to see such
a big structure in a universe that is
meant to be on average homogeneous so a
quasar is very very bright nucleus of a
galaxy it's so bright it actually
outshines the whole galaxy around it the
picture we have of these things is we
believe that pretty much every galaxy
has one of these massive black holes in
the middle and probably what's happening
where you see a quasar is it just means
that that black hole is particularly
active which means stuff is falling into
it which is making it light up
and so when these things were first
discovered they were called quasars
because they were called quasi-stellar
objects
which means they look basically like
stars because all you see is this very
bright nucleus of the galaxy it's only
when you look very carefully you see
actually there's a whole galaxy around
it but they're very useful as sort of
light houses because you can see a
quasar at enormous distances all the way
across the universe even if you couldn't
see a normal galaxy what is the scale
above which you would say everything
looks fairly uniform and below which you
expect there to be structures as you
said you know we are you and i
are quite different
in many ways and um and then you can
just go up you know planets are
different stars and then galaxies
they're different from one another and
you keep going to bigger and bigger
scales and you think well there's
nothing homogeneous here when i look
around things are looking quite
different
but the idea is if you go onto large
enough scales and by large enough we're
really talking on scales
of more than a hundred megaparsec a
parsec is about three light years
so we're talking about 300
million light years you have to go
before you begin to sort of suggest that
above that scale things should start
looking very similar so what these
people have found is looking at the
distribution of quasars in space they're
not randomly distributed that's not news
but what they've actually found is that
they form these incredibly large
structures when you start kind of
mapping out the quasars you find they
form these enormous filaments the latest
thing that they found which this paper
is all about is a structure where the
longest dimension of it is fairly
elongated and the longest dimension of
this collection of quasars is about 4
billion light years long and bearing in
mind that the entire universe is only
about 13 billion light years across so
this is almost a third the size of the
universe this structure so it's a huge
collection of these things
that sounds like the ultimate elephant
in the room that sounds like
it sounds like it's the dominant beast
of the universe and actually it causes a
problem because
the
the picture we have is that when you go
to large scales the universe is supposed
to be homogeneous there's this thing
called the cosmological principle that
says that one bit of the universe is
really very much like another bit of the
universe and of course if you've got
a structure this big it really means
that one bit of the universe isn't very
much like another bit of the universe
because one bit's got this massive
structure in it and another bit hasn't
got this massive structure in it the big
question is whether that is a is it real
is it a real feature i can't really
comment on that i mean i just find it
mind-blowing that the idea you can have
73 quasars
linking across a distance of 4 billion
light years it just blows my mind
and so how do they determine that
they've got this structure but let's
assume it is let's assume it's a real
structure the next question is is it
compatible with an idea that the
universe on large scales is homogeneous
it could be
that there we know there are
fluctuations in the universe that's
homogeneous there has to be because
without those fluctuations we wouldn't
form you wouldn't form structures so it
could be that what we're seeing is just
a rather extreme fluctuation which is
perfectly consistent
and in fact there is a slightly smaller
structure that has been that was
observed a couple of years ago
called the sloan great wall this was
also seen in the sloan
survey
this is a structure of a two to three
hundred megaparsecs so it's not quite as
big as this one and even then that was
pushing the idea of homogeneity so
here's this structure that they've
identified which uh as i say is about
this sort of from end to end here is
about four billion light years long and
so they've sort of played this game of
joy in the dots they've found where all
the quasars are and found where all
their nearest neighbors are and use that
to kind of span between them to say look
that you know it looks like there's a
structure here you have to be very
careful when you're playing this game
because if you just threw down a bunch
of quasars at random once in a while
they start forming things that look like
structures and so the exercise that you
have to go through once you've found
something that looks like a structure
say is this consistent with just kind of
a random collection of things and i just
happen to have seen them arranged in
this way
and the statistics they've done in this
paper show
that what they found is very unlikely to
be just a random distribution of things
it really looks like they found a real
structure in that sense there's a
collection of these quasars which have
formed into this arrangement of quasars
which is not consistent with them just
being randomly splattered around the
place now the model that we're talking
about just to give this
try and put some flesh to these bones is
the universe is very smooth on very
large scales so if i think of the matter
distribution in the universe i think of
it as a mill pond
and that mata distribution is perfectly
flat the mill pond's perfectly flat
that's your homogeneous bit but on top
of it there are these little ripples
right
coming from fish
and some of those are fish and so these
ripples are there and those are the
small fluctuations
so you've got the background homogeneous
everything's smooth and then you've got
the small fluctuations and where you've
got slight excess fluctuations that
means the the gravitational pull you've
got slight more slightly more matter so
from
from newton's law where the force of
attraction is proportional to the mass
you've got slightly more here that will
cause things to attract to it
and then then it'll leave regions which
are where it's
attracting mata from they'll be devoid
of matter they actually will create
voids the force that we think shapes the
large scale structure of the universe is
gravity it falls forces things to
collapse in certain dimensions and so
actually you end up forming these sort
of sheets of things and filaments and
those kinds of things which we've seen
all the time when we look at galaxies in
the nearby universe we find they're not
randomly spread there are some places
where there are clusters of galaxies
some places where there are none at all
some places where they form into these
sort of sheet-like structures or
filament-like structures so presumably
the physics is the same on these scales
which forming these very large scratches
is gravity's forcing things to collapse
in certain directions
the problem is that that's not what
theory predicts right the picture we
have of the universe says that the
gravity shouldn't have formed structures
on these kinds of scales so that's why
it's starting to kind of start to
challenge
our picture of cosmology is that
it seems to be there but we're
struggling a bit to come up with an
explanation as to how it might form
which of course is that that's when
science starts getting interesting when
you start finding things that you
weren't expecting to find in that
analogy you made with the
the fish or whatever it was making
little ripples on our mill pond what's
the reality in the real universe what's
causing these fluctuations that allow
large structures to form okay so this is
this is where it's really fun all right
now we're moving back to the very early
universe
how early about 10 to the minus 35
seconds into the universe that's real
point zero zero zero zero zero zero
thirty
five thirty four zeros and a one okay
seconds
into the universe
and this is the period known as where
the universe expanded exponentially
quickly and and so the this space
uh expanded exponentially rapidly
and in that universe was a thing called
a scalar field a bit like the higgs
field permeating the whole of the
universe and it fluctuated because of
quantum mechanics just like the higgs
field fluctuates randomly randomly and
those fluctuations this the big
difference that goes on here is that
those fluctuations don't just remain
small because the universe is expanding
so rapidly they quickly get
the ex
they're grabbed hold of i'm getting too
excited i'm speaking too quick slow down
i will never accuse you of speaking too
quickly
these fluctuations get uh grabbed hold
of by the expansion of the universe and
stretched onto big big scales and those
are the cosmological scales and it's
it's there that the initial seeds came
from so what we're seeing
when we look at the large-scale
structures in the universe when we look
at the microwave background fluctuations
in the w map
and see these hot and cold spots what
you're actually seeing is an imprint
of those very early moments way before a
microsecond way before a nanosecond into
the universe's history when these
fluctuations from the field emerged a
big blown up projection of just a funny
little wobble in a field
wow
and see the structures that we see and
uh